the ball in the hands of jimmy butler
and either he's getting fouled or going
to the free-throw line
or making the milwaukee bucks
have the best record again in the nba
the best defense
best offense
second consecutive mvp for entertacumbo
a second time all-star in middleton
leading three-point shooter in the
league in hill
sailing along with 56 wins
and just were never right in the restart
didn't play well at both ends of the
floor
and just couldn't get the engine going
kev
in the third quarter milwaukee tonight
reggie
cut miami's lead to one then milwaukee
went scoreless over the next six and a
half minutes
and they just couldn't hit the clock and
that's on divincenzo
and he's gone the second buck to foul
out
middleton before d vincenzo
a lot of off-season questions for
milwaukee well i mean
they're innumerable i mean back-to-back
years you've had the
overall best record and you
last year you know that the two games to
none lead on toronto lost four
straight yes here they were down three
zip
to the fifth seed miami
it's crowder hits
and they've got uh well you mentioned
they're off season it'll be about as
interesting and offseason as
we've seen certainly like in the past
years with lebron and
katie and everybody else and at some
point with the honors
they're gonna offer him the super max
[Music]
and if he does not sign it
what does that tell
[Applause]
the miami heat are looking at an
eight in one playoff record that'll
bring a smile to your face
from everybody i'm sure they're going
why not us right you come here and
reggie it's a neutral floor there is no
home court advantage there is no travel
it's like a laboratory everything is the
same temperature same
room same food everything is equal
and people were expecting to have
strange things happen
and this is pretty strange this hasn't
happened
a number five going to the conference
finals since memphis in 2013.
so your principles start to get
highlighted and
you think of the dna and the toughness
of miami
their versatility their athleticism
they're well coached
that's it the milwaukee bucks lose the
best team in the nba
is gone and the miami heat
going to the eastern conference finals
for the first time in
six years for reggie and rebecca kevin
harlan
so long from orlando